Transcriptor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Manu Ginóbili
Ser distinto
Desde hace muchos años que sigo a TED, que me gusta mucho escuchar sus charlas.
Y, la verdad, es que soy un admirador.
Desde el momento que me dijeron la posibilidad de pasar del otro lado de la cámara,
o del otro lado del escenario, la idea me encantó.
El problema fue cuando me dijeron de qué les gustaría que hablase.
Me dijeron de "Ser distinto".
Ahí puse freno de mano y me puse a pensar de nuevo porque,
realmente, no estaba seguro de poder y estar capacitado de hablar de eso.
Además, me dio mucho miedo.
Cómo hablar de un tema semejante, primero si nunca lo había pensado,
nunca lo había analizado.
Nunca me lo habían preguntado.
Y sin sonar pedante o arrogante, ¿cómo hablar de ese tema?
Pero me encantó el desafío.
El camino a pensar a llegar hasta ahora,
ponerme enfrente de la cámara y analizar qué me pasó, cómo fue,
cómo lo fui sintiendo, cómo se fueron dando estos pasos en mi carrera
para llegar adonde estoy parado ahora.
Y, la verdad, que lo disfruté mucho.
Y me gustó y espero que sepan entenderlo.
Que trato de abstraerme un poco de quién soy
y simplemente explicarlo como un espectador que fue viendo cada paso.
Resulta que a los 15 años nada, absolutamente nada, hacía pensar que yo me iba a destacar,
para nada, en el básquet, absolutamente.
No era un chico prodigio, para nada.
No era un Lebron James,
o un Messi o un
mismo, Escola o Nocioni en el básquet.
Que a los 15 ya se sabía que iban a jugar en un futuro en la selección nacional.
Mi caso era muy distinto.
Yo era muy flaquito, muy chiquito.
Lo único que me diferenciaba, que me podía llegar a diferenciar,
ni siquiera me diferenciaba, era una gran pasión por lo que hacía.
Me gustaba muchísimo.
Además a los 15 años ya mis hermanos eran profesionales.
Ya vivían del básquet.
Y yo no quería ser menos.
Así que a partir de ese momento le empiezo a dedicar mucho más tiempo.
Me empiezo a meter en un gimnasio.
Empiezo a insistirle a mi mamá para que me consiguiera un dietólogo
para tratar de crecer y desarrollarme mejor.
Empiezo a ver videos de básquet.
Y, ni bien termino de ver los videos de básquet,
¡pum! corriendo a la cancha para tratar de copiarlos.
Pero recuerdo que iba, jugaba los partidos y cuando terminaba, volvía a casa,
ya sea contento por haber ganado y jugado bien
o triste y deprimido por haberlo hecho mal,
pero me autoevaluaba frente al espejo.
Me ponía enfrente de la ducha y me gritaba: "¡Perro!"
O, "¡Qué desastre! ¿Así querés jugar en la liga nacional?"
O, "¿así querés ser como tus hermanos?"
Y era duro conmigo mismo.
Pero si las cosas iban bien como que me festejaba.
Me alentaba.
Me decía: "¡esta es la manera de seguir!"
Así que, bueno, todas esas horas que le fui poniendo al, dedicando al, básquet
de a poquito fueron dando algún que otro fruto.
Ya me sentía un poco más crecido, más desarrollado.
Empezaba a saltar un poco más.
Y a los 18 años se me da la posibilidad de transformarme en profesional del básquet.
Me voy a jugar a La Rioja, con muchas dudas,
obviamente, como cualquier chico a los 18 años yéndose a 1.500 km de casa.
Pero con muchas dudas llego.
Muy entusiasmado.
Muy contento de estar siguiendo los pasos de mis hermanos y viviendo del básquet.
Pero aún todavía no creía que estaba dentro mío.
No creía que tenía nada que me hacía diferente.
Jugué algunos partidos, me fue bien dentro de todo,
pero nada me hacía destacar más allá de lo que se destacaba
un chico de mi edad jugando en la liga nacional.
Simplemente había vestigios o cosas que indicaban que me podía llegar a transformar
en un muy buen jugador de liga nacional.
Pero no mucho más.
Al año siguiente vuelvo a Bahía Blanca.
Vuelvo a Estudiantes de Bahía Blanca.
Y ese desarrollo sigue siendo muy paulatino, pero lo siento.
De a poco las cosas me empiezan a salir con más naturalidad.
Por momentos tengo grandes partidos donde se veían cosas
que hasta hace unos meses atrás no creía que podía.
Pero hay un momento clave en ese año,
que es una charla con un extranjero que jugaba conmigo, que había jugado en la NBA.
Había jugado 2 ó 3 años en la NBA.
Y me sienta y me dice: "Te tenés que ir a Estados Unidos.
Tenés que ir a estudiar a una universidad de EE.UU.
que si vos vas y estás 4 años ahí, terminás en la NBA".
Yo lo miro como diciendo "¡Imposible!
Este quiere ser mi amigo o algo y me lo dice para motivarme o para hacerme poner bien".
Ahí en el '97 se da un paso muy importante en mi carrera
que fue jugar el primer mundial.
Y si bien me fue bien, tuvimos un gran campeonato, fue un gran éxito,
tampoco sentía que era distinto en ese entorno.
Es más, no era ni cerca el mejor jugador o el referente del equipo en esa selección.
Pero al volver, ya sabiendo que había representado a la Selección,
ya sabiendo que estaba dentro de la elite de los chicos de mi edad de todo el país,
es como que en mí empezó a haber un cambio.
Sobre todo en autoestima, en confianza.
Así que llegué a jugar la que iba a ser mi última temporada en Argentina
con mucha más confianza.
Como con la frente más alta.
Inmediatamente me puse dos objetivos muy claros.
Uno era jugar el mundial mayor al año siguiente a los 21 años, en Atenas.
Y el otro era emigrar.
Tratar de medirme con jugadores mejores que yo para tratar de alzar esa vara.
Como que creía que ya Argentina había cumplido lo que yo quería hacer.
Logro los dos objetivos.
Voy primero al mundial y después me voy a Italia.
En Italia es todo como un progreso de a poco, por pasos.
Porque yo llego a la segunda división de Italia.
No llego de entrada a lo que sería, no sé, el Milan en el fútbol.
Al año siguiente ascendemos.
Entonces ya paso a jugar en primera división.
Siento que me sigo destacando, que me siguen pasando cosas distintas,
pero vuelvo a atribuírselo a que era un equipo chico.
Un equipo… el típico equipo sorpresa donde, sí, yo me destacaba
porque era un conjunto de jugadores con un talento un poco más limitado.
Pero al año siguiente viene el, supuestamente, mejor equipo de Europa
y me compra a este equipo, compra mi pase, a este equipo menor.
Y ahí es como que sí, llego al lugar donde yo quería estar.
Un equipo con chances de salir campeón.
Un equipo con grandes jugadores.
Y en el que yo iba, de entrada, a tener un rol menor.
No les digo que no iba a jugar nunca pero no iba a ser titular ni iba a tener toda
la preponderancia en el juego que venía de tener en el equipo de segunda división.
Obviamente.
Pero ahí sí que se da el salto de calidad más grande que tuve en mi carrera.
Salimos campeones, recuerdo, de la Copa Italia;
que es una copa menor, pero local.
Después, de la liga italiana.
Y después, de Europa.
Y en ese momento, automáticamente, me pasa
lo que me había pasado 3 años atrás al decir:
"ya está, yo acá… era lo que vine a buscar. Yo vine a salir campeón, a mejorar,
a competir con los mejores, pero los que tengo ahora a mi alrededor
ya no son mejores que yo".
Ya me consideraba en la elite de lo que era el campeonato europeo.
Entonces, el paso siguiente, natural, y único que quedaba era la NBA.
Y, entonces, se me da.
Viene San Antonio Spurs -me había elegido un par de años antes-
pero decide contratarme.
Y, bueno, llego a un mundo totalmente distinto,
que había visto sólo por T.V. hasta hace 5 ó 6 años atrás,
en el que realmente ni esperaba llegar y ser parte de él.
Pero, bueno, se me dio.
Estaba ahí y no me iba a quedar con eso.
Sino que quería mejorar.
Quería triunfar y quería hacerlo bien.
Por primera vez en mi carrera, en ese año, me encuentro con dificultades.
No lograba tener una asiduidad de juego, una regularidad,
que yo creía que podía tener.
Venía con muchas lesiones.
Me había lesionado en el mundial, en el 2002 justamente.
Y cada vez que empezaba a jugar un poco caía con una lesión.
Y, además, simplemente tenía un rol muy limitado.
A mí me daban órdenes, yo tenía que estar en ese rincón, esperar el juego,
hacer esto, hacer lo otro, pero no sentía que estaba
dando al juego todo lo que yo tenía adentro.
Así que fueron 3, 4, 5 meses bastante complicados,
en los que en ningún momento perdí la confianza en mí mismo,
sabía que con el tiempo se iba a dar,
pero ya me estaba impacientando un poco.
La verdad que sí porque por naturaleza soy impaciente.
Pero bueno, sobre el final de la temporada empieza a cambiar de a poco.
Noto en mis compañeros y en el cuerpo técnico como una confianza superior.
Ya por momentos me dejaban 25 ó 30 minutos en la cancha.
Cerraba los juegos.
Me nombraban en alguna jugada para mí, para que yo definiera.
Y eso me empezó a sentir bien.
Pero, les digo la verdad, en este nivel vuelvo a sentir
lo que había sentido anteriormente de decir:
"no sé, me faltan cosas, no sé si tengo lo que se necesita para transformarme
en un gran jugador en la NBA o para destacarme, salirme de lo que es el promedio".
Cosa que sí se empezó a dar en los siguientes dos años.
Pero sobre todo por un hecho puntual.
Un hito clave en mi carrera, en el básquetbol argentino
y en la historia del deporte argentino,
que fue los Juegos Olímpicos del 2004.
Lo que yo sentí, y lo que mi equipo sintió en ese momento, es único.
Es irrepetible para cualquier atleta que no haya estado en esa situación.
Se me pone la piel de gallina en este momento de recordarlo.
Y todo lo que nosotros vivimos creo que gestó una confianza superlativa.
O sea, yo después de ganar ese campeonato olímpico,
después de celebrarlo con mis compañeros, es como que volví a la NBA
con una mentalidad totalmente distinta.
Sabiendo que ya no tenía que demostrar nada.
Yo era campeón olímpico junto con mi equipo argentino.
Habíamos eliminado a Estados Unidos y no había nada que tenía que probar cada día.
No era lo mismo que un año atrás.
Entonces, con esa tranquilidad y el hecho de haber eliminado toda esa presión
empiezo a jugar con más tranquilidad.
Empiezo a sentir el reconocimiento no sólo de mis compañeros y entrenadores
sino también de los rivales.
Y eso cambió mucho en mí.
Cambió mucho porque cuando uno juega ya sabiendo y con ese respeto
lo hace de una manera mucho más tranquila, y afianzada.
Entonces, a partir de ahí se fueron dando muchas cosas.
Volví a ganar un campeonato de NBA.
Me nombraron All-Star, que es la elite; los 24, teóricamente, mejores jugadores de la NBA.
Cosa que, si ya era impensado jugar en la NBA, imagínense formar parte de ese grupo.
Así que notaba que ya me empezaban a pasar demasiadas cosas.
Que ya no podía ser casualidad.
Y que algo había.
Entonces me puse a pensar,
o en realidad me pongo a pensar ahora también:
¿qué era lo que pasaba?
¿qué había?
¿por qué a mí?
¿yo había trabajando mucho más que los demás?
Creería que no.
Porque, sí, había trabajado mucho pero no creo que más que el resto.
Talento, es la palabra a la que llegué.
Es la palabra que me decían.
Mucho talento.
Pero, ¿qué es el talento?
O, ¿cuántos talentos hay?
Entonces yo me puse a pensar y sí, el talento que tenía a los 20 años
era muy difícil…
¡muy difícil!...
muy distinto de lo que después le fui agregando a mi juego.
Yo con el talento de los 20 años posiblemente en bruto era lo mismo que ahora…
no me alcanzaba para llegar a ningún lado.
Había que ir agregándole cosas.
Entonces llegué a la conclusión, y después de todas mis experiencias en equipos,
que talentos hay muchos.
Un talento muy importante es ponerse un objetivo.
Ponerse un objetivo y no dejarse distraer.
No irse por las ramas sino buscarlo, identificarlo,
y hacer todo lo que esté posible a tu alcance para conseguirlo.
Otro talento importante es entender qué es lo que pasa a tu alrededor.
¿Qué es lo que necesita tu equipo?
¿Cuál es la idea de tu entrenador?
¿Qué es lo que falta?
¿Qué es lo que podés agregar para que tu equipo dé el salto de calidad?
Bueno, identificar todo eso y ser capaz de proveerlo.
Otra cosa importante es saber, en determinados momentos,
relegar el lucimiento personal para que tu equipo gane.
O sea, yo puedo ser, yo o cualquiera, 30 puntos en el equipo
y disfrutarlo porque, es verdad, es divertido. Entretiene.
Pero cuando das el siguiente paso por ahí tenés que hacer 10
y después llamar la atención y buscar a tu compañero
para que tu compañero también esté bien.
Otro talento muy importante que lo acabo de decir también recién
es el disfrutar de jugar con tus compañeros.
No estar siempre pendiente de lo que hace uno.
Sino ponerse contento cuando doy un pase y mi compañero define.
Cuando veo que un debutante que está jugando conmigo va creciendo,
y se va desarrollando en un jugador superior.
Porque además de sentirse bien y de altruismo, ayuda al equipo.
Cuanto mejor sean mis compañeros mejor va a ser mi equipo
y más chances voy a tener de ganar.
Y el último, pero no menos importante,
es el de entender tus limitaciones.
Hay simplemente momentos en que no se puede.
Que no se puede todo.
Por más que uno se crea con capacidad para hacerlo hay momentos que no da.
Que hay un equipo que te supera.
Una estrategia que es más importante que el lucimiento personal.
Y yo he tenido la suerte, posiblemente, en todos mis equipos
de jugar con algunos de los mejores jugadores con talentos no habituales,
no de los que se ve y de lo que se lucen, pero que eran los primeros
en levantar la mano cuando había que defender al mejor rival.
Eran los primeros que iban a fajarse adentro cuando el partido se ponía duro.
Y que en ningún momento pensaron o contemplaban la posibilidad
de que hablaran de ellos en la nota post-partido.
En que el fan cantara su nombre.
No era el objetivo.
El objetivo era poner su granito de arena para que el equipo ganara.
Y ahí sí festejar todos juntos.
Creo que esos 5 que nombré son los que hacen que todo se junte
para formar un equipo ganador y un jugador completo.
Son cosas importantísimas para poder marcar una diferencia con el de al lado.
Hay jugadores que tienen uno y les alcanza.
Otros que tienen tres.
Otros que pueden reunir los cinco y son los que marcan una diferencia.
Pero no se queden con la sensación, con la idea,
de que el talento es solamente hacer la jugada linda.
Porque no lo es.
Todo esto que acabo de explicar fue lo que me sirvió
para destacarme en el mundo del básquet.
Algo a lo que le dediqué, básicamente, mi vida entera.
Pero que, lamentablemente, tiene una fecha de vencimiento.
Y una fecha de vencimiento que no es a los 65 o a los 70 años
como a un abogado, un contador o un trabajador cualquiera.
La fecha de vencimiento mía es máximo a los 40 años.
Donde una persona normal que haya estudiado básicamente empieza a arrancarla.
¿Cómo afrontar eso cuando sé que empieza una vida nueva,
una vida distinta fuera del deporte, en la que nunca me he manejado?
Una vida en la que no va a haber las secreciones de adrenalina
o la clase de emociones que yo viví con anterioridad.
Pero es normal. No van a estar.
¿Cómo repetir las sensaciones que yo tuve cuando sonó el silbato final en Atenas
y me abracé, casi llorando, con mis amigos y compañeros
de la Selección festejando una medalla dorada?
Imposible.
¿Cómo repetir el cosquilleo en el estómago, la presión que sentí, antes del partido
número siete contra Detroit en las finales del 2005 sabiendo que había 20.000 personas
en la cancha mirándonos, más de 100 millones en sus casas mirándolo por T.V.,
y con la certeza de que no había un mañana, de que no podía fallar?
Era el que ganaba festejaba.
El que perdía a casa con la cabeza gacha.
¿Cómo repetir eso?
No se puede.
¿Cómo hacerlo a los 40 años cuando uno acaba de llegar,
simplemente, a la mitad del trayecto?
¿Cómo será el segundo tiempo de mi vida cuando sé que absolutamente nada
de lo que haga de ahora en más va a ser ni remotamente parecido
a lo que hice con anterioridad?
A lo que hice antes: a los 30, a los 28, a los 32.
¿Cómo tratar de sobresalir, de destacarme en lo que decida hacer de ahora en más?
Y lo que más me hace pensar y evaluarlo es:
¿realmente me interesa?
Gracias.